-So today, we're going through
New York's scariest
haunted house, Blood Manor.
I gotta be honest, I -- roller
coasters, I'm okay.
I can do a little bit.
I do not like being scared.
I'm for real scared.
-You --
Here's what --
I want to say this.
You jump out at me
if you want to.
You gonna get a boot
to the neck.
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-I get it.
It's like a thing of snakes.
It's gonna --
Aah!
-Come on, Jimmy.
You making it worse.
-You stepped on my foot.
-You making it worse, man.
[ Both scream ]
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
Now step into the Manor.
♪♪
-Hey, Jimmy, look.
[ Chuckles ] Give me a hand.
[ Screams ]
-[ Screaming ]
[ Both screaming ]
-Oh, no!
I don't like this dark [bleep]
-I don't know.
With me?
Kevin!
-Ah!
[ Both speak indistinctly ]
-Yo!
Yo, man.
I don't know where to go.
♪♪
[ Both screaming ]
This way, this way, this way.
-Oh [bleep]
Oh [bleep]
-[ Screams ]
-No. Hey, Jimmy.
-Yeah.
-I farted.
[ Both scream ]
I had gas.
Hold on, brother.
I don't know what type of freaky
stuff you into,
but that needs to stop.
Oh.
Oh. Okay.
-No, no, no. No, no, no.
-Finish doing what you doing.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Ahhh!
♪♪
-[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Go, go.
-Where you going?
Come back!
-No, no, no.
-How 'bout a dollar?
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah. Jimmy's got all the cash.
Whoa! Shoot.
I -- My bad.
My bad.
Go ahead.
-Can't see anything.
-Be careful.
-[ Growls ]
-[ Screams ]
-Hey, come here!
Ahh.
-Just --
-I can't see nothing.
[ Screeching ]
♪♪
-Whoa!
[ Screaming ]
♪♪
[ Both scream ]
-Stop it.
-Stop it. Stop it.
Stop it.
-Stop it.
-You stop it.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Screaming ]
♪♪
[ Screaming ]
-Go on, put them on.
♪♪
-[ Screaming ]
Let me out!
♪♪
-[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Where?
-Is that it?
-[ Laughs ]
-Is it over?
Listen, if we -- if you guys
watch this,
and at any point
it looks like I was afraid,
I'm an actor.
That's acting.
-Alright.
-I'mma lay down.
-[ Growls ]
-Come on, brother. Hey.
I'm out. I'm out.
-Happy Halloween, dude.
-Hey, why don't you
go [bleep] yourself, Jimmy?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know how this game works.
We polled the audience,
and if you can guess
what they'd rather do,
you win that round.
Kevin, the first dilemma
is for you.
[ Clears throat ]
We asked our studio audience,
would you rather be able
to be singing better
than Beyoncé
or run faster than Usain Bolt?
Kevin, which answer
did people choose?
-Okay.
-It's got to be sing.
-Well, you've got to look
at the audience, you know?
This doesn't look like an
audience
that wants to sing.
You know, you guys look like
a bunch of people
that need to escape.
Yeah.
-I think they look like
performers and entertainers.
-These people want to be fast.
These people want
the speed of lightning.
They want to be faster
than Usain Bolt.
-Let's see.
-That's what I would say.
-Let's see
what the audience says.
64% said sing better
than Beyoncé.
[ Buzzer sounds ]
Oh.
-What is wrong with you people?
-Oh, come on.
-We don't want to run.
We'd rather just sing.
-That's the stupidest
thing I've ever seen.
-Hey, come on.
-The next question is for Jimmy.
-Yes.
-Jimmy.
We asked the audience --
-I know my audience.
I love my audience.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Would you rather be trapped
in Jurassic Park
or compete in The Hunger Games?
Which one did
more people choose?
-Oh, that's easy.
That's easy?
-That's an easy one.
-That's so easy, because --
By the way,
I was in "Jurassic World,"
-They would much rather
be trapped in Jurassic Park.
Yeah.
-Why are you trying to --
-I'm not trying
to tell you nothing.
I looked at one guy when they
said it
and he was like,
"Yah, yah, yah."
-Yeah, I'll definitely say
trapped in Jurassic Park.
-Let's see
what the audience says.
♪♪
60%!
-Yes!
-Oh!
-I love you guys! I feel it!
I feel them.
-Okay.
-That was in reverse.
-I know.
-Kevin, next question
goes to you.
-Yeah.
-We asked the audience,
would you rather have
a clone of yourself
that you can boss around...
Sure.
...or have a pet dog
who can talk?
-Whoa, that's tough.
-Choice is yours, Kevin.
-That's tough.
-Look how cute the dog is.
-Wait a minute.
-Does anybody else
hear the dog talk?
Like, other people can
understand the dog?
-Yeah.
-Wait, a pet who can talk.
So, other people can hear the
dog.
-If I had a clone of myself,
does he get to do the bad things
that I wish
I could do that I can't do?
-Well, you can only
boss him around.
-So, if I'm like,
"Go rob that bank
and come back with the money,"
he can do it?
-He can do it.
-This is so tough!
Aah!
-Alright, Kevin!
What is your answer?
-A dog that can talk!
A dog that can talk!
-Let's see what
the audience said.
♪♪
Dog that can talk!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay, it is a barn burner.
Jimmy.
-Yeah.
-You're up next.
-Yeah, here we go.
-We ask "The Tonight Show"
audience, would you rather...
-Oh, I know the answer.
-But they didn't do it yet.
-...be stuck doing
a Robert De Niro
impression for the rest
of your life...
[ Laughs ]
...or a Jerry Seinfeld
impression
for the rest of your life?
-Oh, wow.
-Which one did more
people choose?
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-[ As Jerry ] If you're doing
this the whole time,
you do that, you got to --
I gotta say,
I think I'd rather be Seinfeld!
-Let's see
what the audience says!
-Yes!
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Indistinct ]
-Okay.
[ Thunder rumbles ]
Oh.
You know what that means,
of course.
-Rain?
-It's time
for the final dilemma.
Final dilemma.
-Oh.
-This question is for you,
Kevin.
-Oh, wow.
-You get it right, you win.
You it wrong, Jimmy wins.
-I just pooped a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
-A little bit.
Just a little bit.
-Ah, ol' Depends.
Now, the loser must choose
one of the two dreaded
punishments
waiting for them
on tonight's loser table.
-Come on, man.
-Kevin, here is your question.
We asked
"The Tonight Show" audience,
would you rather be able
to see into the future
or read other people's minds?
The final choice is yours,
Kevin.
-See into the future
or read other people's minds.
-Yes.
-If I can read your mind,
can I technically
see the future?
-No, you can see the present.
I'd be seeing the exact present.
-See into the future or
read other people's minds.
But if I see the future,
I know what to do
and what not to do
because I know what's coming.
If I read your mind,
that doesn't mean
I know what you did
for that moment.
Exactly.
-What is it, Jimmy?!
[ Laughter ]
-Scared me. Scared me.
-You know what? Okay, okay.
See into the future!
-Let's see the audience says.
-Yes! Yes!
-See into the future!
Yes!
Yeah!
-We're going to
the loser's table.
-That's the worst ever.
-Are you ready?
-What is the loser table?
-Oh.
-What do I have to do?
What do I have to do?
-I'm so glad this wasn't me.
-What do I have to do?
-It means, okay,
you must choose
your punishment, Jimmy.
You have two choices.
One is you pick up these worms
with your bare hands
and hold them for 10 seconds
or number dos...
-Aah!
-...eat a cricket.
[ Audience shouting ]
The choice is yours!
[ Laughter ]
[ Indistinct ]
Worm or cricket?
-[ Laughs ]
-Do it.
-Oh! Oh!
-You going with me?
-No, I ain't gonna eat
no cricket!
[ Shouting continues ]
Oh, no!
-Oh.
-The audience is...
I knew you guys
were gonna pick cricket.
-Oh, no, Jimmy!
-"Don't eat me!"
-No, Jimmy!
♪♪
[ All shouting ]
Aah! Aah!
-Oh, oh.
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're the worst friend ever,
and so are you.
Kevin Hart, everybody!
We're here at
the Universal Orlando Resort,
home of the --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This crowd is amazing.
-...home of the greatest
roller coasters in the world.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I love roller coasters,
but they scare me sometimes.
-I don't like them.
-You do not like them.
-I don't like --
You know damn well
I don't like no roller costers,
Jimmy.
-When I shook your hand
this afternoon...
-It was sweaty.
-...it was sweaty.
I'd never -- I've never had --
-Listen, first of all,
I never knew that that could
happen to me until this morning.
Like, my palms was so clammy.
Like, I really -- I don't --
I don't like roller coasters.
And you made me do it.
You made me do it.
-You got -- Well,
with "Think Like a Man,"
we got to act like a man.
We manned up.
We shot the whole thing.
We had to go on it together
'cause I was a little scared,
too.
I've never been
on this roller coaster before.
-Why am I --
I'm getting nervous now.
-I know. We don't
have to do it again.
I'm not going to
make you do it again.
We're riding
the Hollywood Rip Ride Rockit.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The Rip Ride Rockit.
-Insane.
-It's insane.
-Well, anyways, here it is.
Check it out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright, man.
-We got to do this.
-Not even gonna lie to you,
Jimmy. I'm nervous.
I'm nervous, man.
-I mean, I like roller coasters.
I don't like the ones
that go fast.
Hey, guys.
-And now I can't turn back
'cause now I look like a --
I look like a bitch
if I turn back.
Let's just do it.
-Let's do it. Here we go.
Here we go. Here we go.
[ Indistinct ]
-Hey. Sir?
[ Laughter ]
-Sorry, what?
Are you --
Are you serious right now?
-I am serious.
You're good.
-I'm not -- I'm a grown man.
-Alright. Let's go. Let's go.
Let's go, let's go. Kevin.
Let's go.
-He's being straightforward
about it.
-Oh, no.
We're in the front.
-I don't want to do it.
Come on, Kevin,
you have to do it.
You have to do it.
Come on. We said we can do it.
Come on, we can --
-Aah!
-Hey-oh!
Hey-oh!
-Lock me in.
Lock me in. Lock me in, man.
Come on. [ Indistinct ]
No, no, no. Push it further.
Lock it.
Push it as far as it can go.
-Make sure I do what?
-I'm freaking out, man!
Wait! Wait! Wait!
-Let's go! Oh, my God!
-Wait!!
Oh, no!
Oh, God, no!
[ Laughs ]
No! No!
No!
-Oh, my God.
-No! Aah!
Aah! Oh, God!
-Oh, my God!
[ Both screaming ]
-Oh, God! Oh, no!
-Oh! Oh!
Oh, my God! Oh! Oh!
-Stop, stop, stop. Stop it.
Stop.
Stop! Aah!
[ Both screaming ]
-Oh! Oh, no!
[ Indistinct ]
[ Laughter ]
Got hit with a bug!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Sighs ]
-Look at how cool we are.
-No.
-Feel cool, man. Feel real good.
-You look like Doc
from "Back to the Future."
[ Laughs ] You look like --
You look like Marty
just came back from 1976
and you're mad
about what he saw.
[ Laughter ]
-Dude, you did great.
-I did good.
-You did great.
-Let's just go.
It's time to go.
-We're gonna go again.
-We're gonna what?
-One more time! Here we go!
-No! No!
Stop playing, Jimmy! No!
Oh, I can't. I can't.
I can't, y'all. I can't!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You were crying.
-I got tears!
-I mean, look. He got tears
in his eyes right now.
-I got tears!
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
-Good news is you never have
to ride a roller coaster again.
Man, that was so fun.
-I'm very, very excited
that you're here today.
Thank you, buddy.
-I'm excited to be here, man.
You know, Jimmy,
first and foremost, dude,
I'm too pumped up.
You know I've been
telling everybody about this.
But there's there's one person
I forgot to tell.
Do you mind if I make
a FaceTime real quick?
Just real quick, I promise.
-You're gonna FaceTime?
-Yeah, I just forgot to tell one
person.
-Who are you gonna FaceTime?
-You know, just a close friend
of mine, somebody I'm very close
to.
You may know him.
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson.
[ Cheers and applause,
cellphone ringing ]
-I know him.
We love Dwayne Johnson.
-Listen, he's not gonna be able
to believe that I'm here.
Watch this. Watch.
He's gonna be so pumped up that
I'm here tonight, man.
Wait till he picks up.
I know he's gonna be pumped up
about it. Hold on.
Wait a second. Hold on.
One sec. Let me try --
Let me just try him...
-Maybe he's driving or
something.
-No, he's not driving.
He's got a chauffeur.
That guy's -- He's got a lot of
people that drive for him.
He's just -- He probably doesn't
see it.
Give him two minutes.
He'll pick up.
Watch. He's gonna pick up.
I'm gonna try him again.
Watch this.
Watch this. He's gonna go crazy.
Watch this. As soon as he picks
up in, like, two seconds.
He's gonna go --
He's gonna go crazy.
The fact that I'm here
and that you're here.
-We can edit all this out.
We can edit all this out.
-You don't have to edit it out.
Just give me a second.
That's crazy.
Now, that's honestly crazy.
'Cause normally he picks up.
-I have his number.
-What?
-You know Dwayne like that?
You got his number?
Well, he's not gonna pick up.
He's busy.
So, this isn't -- You can try,
but I doubt
that he picks up the phone.
He would've picked up for me.
I'll text him.
[ Cellphone chimes ]
I'mma text him
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
-Hey!
-Dude, Dwayne, what's up?
What's up, pal?
-What's going on, Jimmy?
How you doing, brother?
-Everything's great, man.
I just -- Yeah. I just
figured -- I'm doing the show.
I just figured I'd FaceTime you,
see what you're doing.
What are you -- Are you busy?
-Oh.
-Are you busy?
-Well, I'm just getting ready to
head to work.
I'm going to shoot "The Titan
Games," which you know.
-That's right. "Titan Games"
on NBC. That's great.
-Yeah, on NBC. It's cool.
I wanted to make something that
was big and fun, by the way,
like our nickname,
'cause we're best friends --
Big and Fun,
you know what I mean?
-Absolutely. That's it.
-But, hey, it's crazy.
It's crazy you were just
FaceTiming me.
Kevin Hart was FaceTiming.
He just -- He continues to,
like, text me.
He just FaceTimed
me like two times.
I'm like,
"Dude, just end -- end it."
[ Laughter ]
You know what's crazy,
look, about Kevin -- and I know
you're shooting a show,
and the audience will love this,
too,
'cause they probably feel
the same way --
Kevin to me is like --
is like a little gremlin that...
that I just want to take him and
throw him into oncoming traffic.
-Oh, yeah. Yeah. It's good.
It's always good --
It's good to talk to you, buddy,
and we love you,
and --
-Oh, I love you back.
-Just checking in on you.
Just want to make sure
everything's cool, man.
-Oh, hey, and one more thing,
dude.
Of course the most important
thing --
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
-Ah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
You're the best, buddy!
Thank you so much.
I'll talk to you later.
-Alright, man!
-Bye, buddy. Bye-bye.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Uh...
[ Laughter ]
He wasn't there.
It went straight to voicemail.
[ Laughter ]
-I heard the whole conversation!
-Give it up for Dwayne Johnson,
everybody!
-Drinko, would you like to
explain how this game works?
-[ Robotic ] Yes, Mr. Hart,
Mr. Fallon, welcome to Drinko.
In this game, the two of you
will take turns
climbing my stairs and dropping
two of your colored discs
into the Drinko board.
The disc will clink down
and land in these plastic cups
containing some of
my favorite beverages,
such as Capri Sun,
mulled wine and pea...
soup.
-I'm sorry, what?
What'd he say?
-Pea soup.
Your opponent
must drink a cocktail
of the two chosen drinks.
-Okay, very good.
Thank you, Drinko.
Kevin, you're our guest.
Why don't you climb up there
and make the first cocktail?
-Pretty easy for me
to climb these stairs
in my cross-training sneakers.
-Oh, give me a break.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Everyone has their --
Yeah, yeah.
-Class.
-Alright.
[ Clears throat ]
-Now drop your first disc,
Kevin.
-Alright, here we go. Come on,
pea soup, come on, pea soup.
Mulled wine.
-Now your second drink.
-What is that?
-Drop your second disc.
-Mulled line is like all sorts
of like cinnamon sticks
and herbs and things.
-Well, I'll tell you
off the bat,
cinnamon sticks give me gas.
So you got to deal with that
on your own time.
-Drop it.
-Ready?
-Wait. Should I get
this one out of the way?
Sorry. Thank you, Drinko.
-There you go.
-How you doing, buddy?
-Not good.
[ Laughter ]
-Here we go.
-Oh, there he goes.
You'll be drinking
mulled wine and...
Hennessy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, Drinko.
-That kills me,
how the Black guy
somehow mysteriously picks
Hennessy. Okay.
Alright. Yeah, okay.
-I did not plan that!
It's all random!
-Yeah, it's all random, right?
Okay, Black guy, what's next?
You got some Colt 45 in there?
-No, come on!
[ Laughter ]
-Geez, boy, I tell you.
-Mix them up.
-I pour it in there, right?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I pour them both in there?
-Yes.
-Alright.
-Glug, glug, glug, glug.
-I got to drink the whole thing?
-I think so, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?
What's y'all problem?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Audience groans ]
-Eww!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good to have you on the show.
Congratulations on everything.
This is what you get.
[ Audience chanting
"chug, chug, chug" ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
[ Laughter ]
-Don't move, don't move,
don't move, don't move.
-James, it's your turn.
Mount me.
-Don't move, Kevin.
[ Laughter ]
-Ascend the staircase.
-Oh, God.
-And drop two discs.
-Oh.
-[ Grunting ]
-Alright.
-Drop it.
-How you feeling?
-[ Hisses ]
-Alright. Alright.
Well, I'm gonna go over
this way maybe.
-Pea soup!
-No, no, no!
No, not pea soup!
-Pickle juice!
-Pickle juice.
Pickle juice is big.
-I didn't even see
pickle juice on there.
-I got it, Drinko.
-You're welcome.
-Thank you, Drinko.
-Nice shoes.
-Hey, thank you, Drinko.
-Hey, no problem.
You look good in blue.
Drop it, James.
[ Audience chanting "pea soup" ]
-No, no, no, no.
[ Chanting continues ]
Oh! No, no, no, no!
No, please, no!
What is it?
-Capri Sun.
-Yes!
Capri Sun and pickle juice.
That's my diet.
That's fantastic.
That's my diet I've been on.
Yeah,
Capri Sun and pickle juice.
-Mmm, so delicious.
-That is so -- That is so --
That's a white guy.
-That looks like champagne.
-It does, right?
That's pickle juice?
-Yes.
-Oh.
-Oh, that don't look good.
[ Audience groans ]
Even though he said that's
Capri Sun, after seeing that,
I don't believe it.
I don't believe it one bit.
-Alright.
This looks gross. Okay.
[ Audience chanting
"drink, drink, drink" ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ugh.
-Not too shabby, James.
Now for the final round.
Both of you fellows are going
to mount me at the same time,
drop a disc into me
simultaneously.
Whosever just lands
in the cup first wins
and the loser has
to combine both cups
and drink the final cocktail.
-Wait.
Whoever dro-- Whoever's disc --
I think I'm drunk.
Let's wait a sec.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm definitely not,
I'm definitely not,
but I'm going to throw up
all over the place.
-He said the first one --
-That goes in --
-Wins.
The other fellow drinks it.
-Okay, so whoever's disc
gets down first.
-Does not have to
drink the beverages.
-I got it.
-[ Grunting ]
Those shoes are so light.
-No wonder why
I beat you up here.
It's because of
my cross trainers.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Ready, gentlemen?
When I say "three,"
drop your disc.
One, two, three.
-Capri Sun and Tang.
James drinks.
-What is it?
-Capri Sun and Tang.
-Capri Sun and Tang?
-No, no!
-Yes!
-No!
It's killing me
how the Black guy got Hennessy!
[ Laughter ]
But he gets all kinds of juice!
-You're the champ.
[ Laughs ]
You're the champ!
Here we go!
-Why do you keep getting juice?!
-Kevin wins.
-Here we go, Tang and Capri Sun.
[ Laughter ]
Always good to see you, man.
You're the best.
I'm so excited about this.
Here we go.
-I should've known it was rigged
when I saw the white glove.
I should've known.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, get --
-Pea soup!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. Yes!
-What'd you have
for breakfast?
-Oh, no, actually,
actually don't do it.
Don't do it, brother.
[ Audience groans ]
-I just want to do --
I'll do a sip.
I'll just do a sip, alright?
-No, you got to drink that
'cause it's at the bottom.
If you're gonna do it, do it.
[ Audience chanting
"chug, chug, chug" ]
♪♪
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Drinko!
-Not bad, actually.
Not bad. Not too shabby.
-Oh, God.
-Hey, Nike, if you're watching,
I'll have my own sneakers,
as well.
I really deserve it.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm the winner?
No, I'm the loser.
Kevin Hart is the champ right
there, everybody. Give it up.
[ Cheers and applause ]